lobbys und berlin freunde reden wir
darüber mit einem der käuflich ssten
menschen die ich persönlich kenne mit
olaf schubert
schön dass sie
wie sieht es bei dir aus würdest du auch
gerne meinen politiker mieten
ich würd einnehmen so also frag mal
irgendwie sohn gabriel nimmt so stießen
auf die wiese der mit ihm alt wird nicht
hochkommen aber natürlich nicht für 7000
euro
dass ich meine es ist die frage wie
setzt man den einwänden hält eine rede
im schlafzimmer und erklärt mir warum es
plötzlich läuft also dass das macht
meine frau ehrenamtlich also ich sag mal
so ich es müsste eigentlich andersrum
sein eigentlich müssten die geld
bezahlen damit sie bei mir zuhören
dürfen aber da bin ich eben anders also
ich poste ihrem ich nicht also ich
profitiere mich auch aber natürlich
nicht für 7000 euro noch eine meldung
aus dieser woche leider auch eine wahre
geschichte im finanzministerium hat über
jahre ein regelrechter maulwurf der
bankenbranche aktiv an gesetzen
mitgeschrieben
die haben also offensichtlich doch sehr
viel einfluss auf die politik die könnte
man da gegensteuern gegenstand warum
also ich meine manchmal sagt doch immer
die die klugen die die es drauf haben
diese in der wirtschaft und in der
politik da sind da sind die anderen also
die die sich jetzt nicht so direkt für
buchstaben interessieren ich will es
nicht sagen dass jetzt alle politiker
dürften aber sammelt die hand beim
denken eben ein bisschen pech und ist ja
gar nicht ob ich meine und wenn es eben
so ein gesetz geschrieben werden muss es
eben so dass die austritt wirtschaft den
den politikern helfen
das fängt bei der rechtschreibung an das
hört irgendwo auf es gibt ein betreutes
wohnen das eben betreutes regieren so
denn so ein gesetz das muss ja wirklich
auch auf den punkt seien präzise zeigt
wie schon in der bibel hier
du sollst nicht begehren deines nächsten
weib werden dass ein politiker machen
würde dann wäre das viel länger die
gesagt du sollst nicht begehren deines
nächsten weib
es sei denn es muss krass sein multi
speziell ja zum beispiel das problem bei
solchen skandalen ist aber dass sie
natürlich dazu beitragen die demokratie
müdigkeit zu vergrößern
über die hälfte der jungen europäer
findet es laut einer aktuellen umfrage
nicht mehr wichtig in einer demokratie
zu leben kommt die demokratie aus der
mode
naja demokratie dafür für den einzelnen
ist das schon stress also du musst alle
vier jahre irgendwie zu wollen hätten
irgendwann nicht mehr so also deshalb
finde ich wichtig dass man den
demokratischen betrieb irgendwie
entschlackt entschlackung genau also
dass der bürger eben wirklich nur noch
dann belästigt wird wenn es ihn wirklich
direkt wenn es voll an die armee senken
dass man eben fragt hier haben sie was
dagegen dass am wochenende die
balkanroute durch und garten geht ja
also ich denke da wird sich
mitbestimmung regen erscheinen was wäre
für dich das beste mittel gegen
populismus populismus heißt ja wenn man
gold um stimmen
sag ich mal mit mit einfachen lösung
aber ist denn was ist denn schlecht am
einfachen oliver frage ich dich mal den
geschlechtsakt also natürlich was denn
so das ist also ich habe gehört dass das
ein sexualpartner der zu bisschen
einfach gestrickt ist also besondere
talente hat können also
und jetzt das heißt auf den populismus
bezogen dass also eine art kommunismus
wie soll man positive positiver
populismus ich meinen ich kann selbst
vermuten dass ich meinen also ich sag es
war alles platt was populismus ist
scheiß es bleibt dabei ohne schufa und
vielen dank